[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in marcus hayes the
philadelphia enquirer columnist
what the hell happened yesterday
they'd had enough they've just had
enough i mean ben's been there for you
know
counting his quarantine more than a week
and um
he hasn't engaged with his teammates he
won't acknowledge people in the building
he talks to the the dealer i guess the
g-league coaches now but he won't talk
to his own coaches i mean he's he's
committing career suicide because dan i
mean
what team
is going to take a chance that he's not
going to do the same thing with them
once he lands there who is he mad at
he's mad at doc rivers for not
continuing to defend him and not
promoting him as a point guard at the
end of last season when they lost game
seven uh one of my colleagues david
murphy asked doc
do you think ben can be the point guard
of a championship team and doc
clearly doesn't
as doc was a point guard himself in a
very similar point guard to ben simmons
and he said i don't know i can't answer
that question he didn't say yes that's
that's the problem and then after doc
spoke
joel embiid was asked what do you think
the turning point of the game was and he
said you know when we didn't make the
when we didn't take the dunk with three
and a half minutes left
so he's mad at them
he's embarrassed
by the reaction from him not taking that
dunk
and
he's kind of
[Music]
he's in a spot i think personally
where he thinks a fresh start changes
everything where philadelphia is mean to
him
and if he gets out of philadelphia
everything will be better because you
know no we're in 19 we're in 1815 and
nobody knows what would happen in
philadelphia wherever he goes next i i
don't know what he's thinking there what
happens today
uh nothing i mean he doesn't go he
didn't fly with the team he's not with
them
um for their first game tonight and i
the sixers are weird because they never
practice after the day after the game
especially a road game so they won't
practice tomorrow doc river said hey you
know we'll see what happens thursday
well nothing's going to happen thursday
guys come in for treatment if they want
it they maybe do some film stuff ben
won't be asked to do the film stuff
because he wasn't involved in the game
so it'll be before the shoot around
friday before we know kind of where the
next shoe drops because there won't be
another practice so
i don't expect him to play anytime soon
i think doc has had enough finally after
a year of carrying water lying for ben
simmons
you know
and insulting anyone who
gained to ask well ben simmons has these
deficiencies
can you fix them this way this way oh
you have to treasure him he's special
i think he's embarrassed of how he acted
last year feels betrayed so does joel
embiid who carried water for him a lot
so i just don't think he's going to play
or get paid more importantly until he
capitulates and i'm not sure that that's
going to happen anytime soon either i
just wonder he he's trying to take the
uh james harden approach he's just not
as good as james harden like james
harden is still valuable even if he's
out of shape and doesn't want to play
for houston
ben simmons still can't shoot he's still
a liability in certain areas here
who's going to want to trade for him
like do you have actual teams that would
actually be interested in him
i mean i think cleveland would be
interested him in him as a rebuilding
centerpiece to sort of do whatever he
wants and market the team
but certainly no contender i mean he's
putting himself in a position where
no team that is viable
can risk
his
psychology can risk his mental state
not to mention the shooting i mean i
think he'd be a spectacular powerful you
know
dennis rodman with a handle draymond
green with you know better even better
passing ability maybe not as good a
defender as draymond but he wants to be
a point guard and he wants to do things
his own way and he wants to be a point
guard who doesn't have to shoot
and doesn't have to
uh be accountable
so
it's it's a very very small box but i
think a place like cleveland where
things are horrible and they're they
need a they need a centerpiece is a spot
they just don't have anything the sixers
would be interested in trading for
to make them
decent you know they don't have pieces
in cleveland that can play that can
break the starting line
well i look at ben you you can't put him
in a situation where it's a high
pressure situation he really has to go
to a team that doesn't have any chance
of winning therefore he doesn't get into
these situations where he doesn't want
to shoot a big big free throw
or make a big play a big dunk and i
agree with you he's not a point guard
he's he wants to be magic johnson well
magic played at a time when he didn't
need to have a jumper he he did get a a
a jumper or at least a set shot
ben doesn't have that you can be six
nine and have a good handle but in
today's nba if you're gonna play the
point got to be able to make free throws
and you got at least be respectable from
you know 15 to 18 feet
or like giannis i mean you have to be
willing to fail
that's the issue with ben it's not that
he can't make free throws i mean he
hasn't lately but it's not that he can't
make free throws at a clip where you
don't hack a ben
in the middle of the game i mean that
that's kind of over
and he's he's not a good shooter but you
can shoot 31
from 15 feet and out and still be a
threat i mean your head fake works
but he won't do it
like giannis has a is not a good shooter
is a you know there's a ritual that you
know road teams go through to embarrass
him on a free throw line but he's so
brave yeah he's so courageous he's such
a man that he doesn't care about that
because he wants to win and he wants to
do what's right he wants to do what's
best and that's the paradox with ben he
wants to go somewhere to win
but he doesn't want to do what it takes
to win
yeah well when you've been coddled and
we talked about the this the last time
that you know why i love giannis because
he had to prove himself he works hard
every i mean he's still working hard and
he's not afraid of being laughed at
embarrassed because he he just wants to
be great ben gets laughed at and then he
wants to go into a show and then say
stop doing that to me instead of
being a man step up and go hey i'm going
to be great i want to be great i want to
prove everybody wrong and he just hey
send me someplace else all right send
you someplace else and then what happens
when things go wrong well i mean in your
profession you've been at the pinnacle
of your profession for years right i'm
near the top of my profession
i have looked ridiculous
thousands of times even you know after i
arrived or whatever i'm sure there are
tapes of dan patrick out there you don't
want anybody to see
but that's what it takes to become
better and that's the other thing that
people don't realize about ben simmons
just because he looks like an adonis and
he's ripped up and he's got a good
handle it doesn't mean he's much better
than he was when he got here from lsu
he he has not progressed as a player or
a person you know he went to lsu under
you know protest
tanked for a year and was the number one
overall pick his plan worked
but he's the same person that i met in
new york city in the ballroom at the
hilton
in the pre-draft uh of media
availability
six years later it's the same guy he's
the same spoiled entouraged um
immature
narcissistic
smart
capable athlete
that he was back then he just hasn't he
hasn't grown
i remember when kobe got embarrassed
when he was 18 years of age the air ball
and the playoffs and but but you know
that was motivation all the great
players are motivated
something jordan jordan would you know
create something to be motivated you
know magic was motivated he wanted to
beat bird bird was motivated like
the greats want to be motivated i don't
know what motivates ben simmons
money and attention that's all he cares
about that's all he's ever cared about
money and attention i mean kobe misses a
free throw he builds a gym in his house
to practice free throws at three o'clock
in the morning you know michael jordan
gets beat up his first year in the nba
he goes back to unc and he starts
working out with the track team and the
football team to get stronger and faster
you're not seeing ben you know working
out with the australian rules football
team national team or the rugby team to
get stronger and faster and better and
tougher you know he's going to wimbledon
with pretty pretty ladies you know he's
buying a house he's going on instagram
and he's showing you
on instagram or twitter
a video of him making
a jump shot that he never takes in the
game
it's insane i mean i i don't care if you
make a thousand of them
in this gym with your trainer take one
in a game
what happens on friday night
i just think it's i think we're in this
holding pattern for a while and he'll be
fined more
and
i i think at some point the sixers may
seek relief you know like a breach of
contract thing and try to get out of the
deal but they're not going to trade him
for nothing
they're just not going to let him win
daryl more is a very difficult guy to
deal with the sixers president and you
know he'll stand on principle until he
can't stand any longer and he's going to
win this he really he really is i mean
clutch sports and rich paul and lebron
james is uh conglomerate are going to
take a big l here and the biggest loser
is going to be ben
because he's going to be if he
if he plays again and that's a
possibility if he plays again
he's never going to be respected he's
going to be a pariah no matter where
he's at when he's on the road he's got
he's going to be a laughingstock
and
he's going to lose hundreds of millions
of potential dollars in earnings
it's just
it's suicide i mean he's got a small
window in the next what month
to get over himself
come back and play here and play well
and get traded to a good team and
refurbishes it refurbishes the image
resurrect himself but that's probably
the end of the window
great to talk to you as always got a lot
to write about there marcus thanks for
joining us again buddy
my pleasure thanks for having me that's
marcus hayes philadelphia inquirer
columnist